[Musique]
ce ne soit rien peu exceptionnelle qui
se tient actuellement sur le campus de
centrale supélec puisqu'on a l'honneur
d'accueillir le directeur général de les
adh l'agencé spatiale européenne il ya
le werder d'accueillir également claudie
haigneré etienne klein et ce plateau
prestigieux en fête a été réunie à
l'occasion d'une table ronde que l'on a
tenu dans le contexte de la création
d'un des zarabes c'est à dire d'un
laboratoire en partenariat avec les avec
l'agencé spatiale européenne donc de
centrale supélec l'objectif de lézat lab
c'est de développer en fait des
coopérations en matière d'enseignement
c'est à dire que les a évidemment un
vivier d'experts et puis des
laboratoires des moyens expérimentaux
très important et une idée c'est de de
profiter de s'appuyer sur ce potentiel
scientifique pour développer des
enseignements développer des visites sur
site des projets avec avec nos élèves
c'est une reconnaissance et c'est un
honneur pour centrale supélec d'avoir
été choisis par les as pour pour faire
ce partenaire pour établir ce
partenariat et mettre en place c'était
valable
c'est évidemment un processus électif
[Musique]
par exemple les 112 à des projets
spécifiques tout contact climate change
and developed and the pipettes fioutch à
widnes
[Musique]